beautifully done another reverse off the
alley ooh mason jones very patient there
ball fake pump him get him to jump and
then throw that pass i mean we know
about the pump fake pump fakes are
that's a good one wow that was a nice
pass
let him beautifully all he had to do was
guide it in
bass will throw it in six minutes to go
pipton on the baseline drive feeds the
cutting kalia jones throwing it down
over milwaukee bay
that was a nice feed by scotty pippen jr
and then the flush
[Music]
palmer stop and go drive gives it away
here's a shot from the corner up and out
pulled down by
coburn
up and out the fall oh my goodness a
little nasty
by jen nathan williams and that brings
the crowd alive
both coaches probably the challenge who
wants to win this game okay so he can go
three-and-oh
oh
bonnie getty a little bark after the
bucket
ellison was
was the sixer who came in the paint and
swatted that last shot away
yes he did right here a little stare
down
but it shows another gear
by giddy
i remember coming out of memphis and he
only played a handful of games in
college wiseman yeah the comp that i
kept hearing was chris bosh wow
and it's oh showtime
punt with a little room service
and my knight is saying that might be me
harrison
and harris
absolutely destroyed come on come on
execution dribble handoff
going left
turn to his strong hand
throwing it down
[Applause]
oh he paid the price as well matt
mitchell got him right across the head
vancaro with another
little bit of room service at the other
end okay
we're in vegas so we'll take some show
time
he'll be here all week
showing exactly why
competing on the defensive end
a little flare up by 11. justin james
the former king
working on the wing
elevating and catching a body underneath
wow big time move nice punch
just defender gives up baseline he's
meeting size at the rim but never
hesitates mark just changes his angle
rather stoic look
the lava tab oh man say it with your
chest
mr jackson
kirkwood out top back to duke
duke
oh my
goodness that's what i'm talking about
that is exactly what i'm talking about
that got the building fired up he's
hurting a little bit but
that's a don't you remember
he says
definitely a lot to like you got a good
coach also
showtime for the wizards
hammers it home
cherry on top
you're not a shooter on that day if your
team misses that many threes in a row
the good thing for the pelicans is
they're only 0 for 3 from the 3-point
line
shot it down
on a very efficient 9 of 16 from the
field
and the tough shooting night continues
for the first round pick wesley showtime
here in las vegas for josh christopher
not a screen for mama kalash really iso
now he has it
iso with jd davidson spins it up
[Applause]
he couldn't get that pass to
holmgren
picked off by terry and the magic coming
back
houston
terry
with a terry touch
he's not making that spin move to score
holmgren wow holy cow
[Applause]
as weisman eventually tracks it down to
control things for the warriors
[Music]
dominguez
that's the play in the summer kaminga
take me through this play in transition
he drives left spins
back to his right and throws it down
with one hand look at this again look at
this look at the
ball control puts it in his right hand
uh recently pleaded guilty to disorderly
conduct following allegations of
assaulting his
[Applause]
they get another opportunity wesley with
a long two
and this time the grizzlies with the
rebound
roddy reason up oh delivering a
hammershot david roddy looked at his
wrist and said i got some time today
[Applause]
respect
we're also seeing some late scratches
which means a lot of guys are going to
get more minutes for the nets noah
kirkwood the rookie out of oh my
goodness
are you serious david dude
they teaching the bigs to do a lot of
guard stuff nowadays oh great time
johnson got a body underneath bought
that great bounce pack guys come with
summer league to get bears well keon
johnson just got his
the finish
adding jericho
to the scene